good morning or good afternoon or good
evening or good night I am not sure
where from whichever locations you have
been attending my talk and thanks for
taking uh time and losing my talk uh so
today I'm going to talk about uh arts
and gotch models to uh
before I actually uh jump into the
context of the talk so let me start with
some Shameless promotion about me uh I'm
a self-taught data scientist an
analytics manager associated with one of
the startup based company in Hyderabad
uh and I also call myself as a community
person because I've been involved with
different Python and data science
Community where I work with different
communities and help them grow So
currently I'm associated with the
following organization where I perform
different roles and responsibilities in
each of these organizations
apart from that I'm also a passionate
mentor and Avid speaker I always look
for an opportunities to share my
knowledge and help people in different
areas in uh data science and machine
learning areas so these are my social
handles if you have any questions
suggestions complaints or anything about
having feel free to you know write it
over this platform and I'll be
responding in each and every message of
yours for sure
okay so here is the agenda for today's
talk we'll give you a quick refresher
about our time series then we'll talk
about the overview of arts and guards
models and we'll see the process of the
Arts and guards models and how we can
build arts and guards models and we'll
do some forecasting and everything we'll
see some action uh and live and uh with
that you know and I'll wrap my talk
accordingly so without any further
delays let's get started
uh time series uh so uh there are so
many definitions of the time series
which are available on the internet out
of which indicate same meaning in a
different way a pretty straightforward
definition is sequential data
observation matters now when we are
talking about time series data the main
aim is to estimate how sequence of our
observations will continue in future so
observations are typically collected at
regular intervals like you know every
hour weekly uh daily monthly yearly etc
etc so depending upon the source of the
generation we may have different
frequencies at which our data is
collected
and uh when we are dealing with the time
series one should have really fair
understanding about the key components
of the time series so the key components
are nothing but like a trend seasonality
uh random variations or cyclic patterns
or stationary patterns so one should
aware of all these pattern one should
have a knowledge of of all these
patterns in order to work on the time
series problems or forecasting problems
because without having a prior knowledge
of these uh base so it is very difficult
to solve the time series for casting
problems
and you know time series I feel like you
know literally spreaded his wings like
you know everywhere uh starting from you
know statistics or econometrics to it's
been there in bioinformatics and
Manufacturing industry so time Series
has been there in every industry now so
that's why it's like you know it's
everywhere now
okay so here comes our main concept
called
models overview so first we'll start
with an RS process uh we'll give you an
overview but actually oh then we'll talk
about our catch models so Arch are
nothing but you know Auto regressive
conditional heterospedacity uh models uh
so we'll talk in detail about each of
these Notions in a while uh but we'll
first try to understand uh what this
model and how this model came into the
picture uh so Arch model was like first
introduced by Robert F angel in 1982 the
reason behind for introducing this model
was like you know uh as we all know that
you know inflation is like you know
always uncertain and it is the primary
cause of a business cycle so think from
an industry investor standpoint like you
know we are as an investor you are not
sure how you are know future prices or
wages should be uh and in such
situations you might not able to you
know uh may or may not able to invest
just uh your money in feature because
the end of the day nobody wants to lose
the money right that is that is a fact
to solve such problems so so we need to
have a Time series problems with a
variant that changes over a Time
so what Robert has done is he has
squared the residuals and fitted a utter
aggressive model that's how the now the
Arts model came into the screen in this
paper called Auto regressive with the
estimate of a variance of UK inflation
so that was his paper and that's how the
Earth model came into the picture uh
came into the picture now now uh in
traditional time series model uh we are
be modeling the mean of a dependent
variable for example we want to predict
the few future price of a stop in the
next quarter uh this is what we have
been doing but here we are focusing
particularly on the conditional variance
the reason behind is like you know
investors and you know financial
institutions may not have been not only
be interested in returns but they also
be actually looking into the variants of
the asset so the not only focusing on
the written but they also keep a tab on
a variance of the assets uh so that's
why like you know variant sorts of plays
a key role
that's what the RX models is all about
uh now with the help of Arma and R so we
can use to explain this a conditional
mean and conditional variance so that's
the beauty of Arts model now let's talk
about the gatch so gut is nothing but a
generalized Auto regressive conditional
heteroscedacity okay so sorry I forgot a
point here uh I I forgot to tell you
about the uh Notions of the the arch
point so heterosphere we'll start with
the heteroskedacity heteroskedacity is
nothing but uh so in English in English
language I mean if you see in the
dictionary language so we have a meaning
called No Hydro is nothing but a
different than skedacity is nothing but
a dispersion so if you look at the
statistics we have a most commonly
measurement of a discussion called you
know standard deviation and variance uh
uh but in our goal in our goal of Arts
we are focusing only on the conditional
variance so so to put it in a simple way
heterosecity is nothing but the
volatility uh and the next we'll talk
about the conditional conditional
nothing but the conditional property
where you know one year one value
depends upon the others and finally uh
the auto regressive is nothing but
depending upon the previous value I'll
not talk in detail about the order
regressive here because the
authenticulous view altogether different
concept I I assume you are already aware
of the regressive models uh yeah so so
what we are doing is we are taking the
uh previous values to measure the
variance uh here so that's how the arch
model constructs here okay coming back
to God uh so gatch is a generalized Auto
regressive heteroskedacity model so this
model is an extension of arch model and
it was introduced by policeleb in 1986.
so what we do in gatch model is like the
conditional variance is expressed as a
linear function of the square root
values of the series meaning that no
garch model allows us to measure the
conditional variance as a arima process
with the help of Pharma process we are
able to measure the conditional variance
year and with the combination of uh with
the guards we can combine a moving
average and auto regressive components
in the heteroscedasticity variant so
that's what we do so to summarize to
summarize the overview of a catch and
model the overall object of these two
model is to analyze and forecast the
volatility so that's what the arch and
guards models does uh in real time
so some of the examples on the same for
Arch and gatch model so these are the
examples now based on uh some financial
data and economic tricks data so if you
look at uh if you look at the first
figure which is basically the absolute
figures of a uh daily log return of FNP
500 where you can see here the
volatility here and if you also look at
the absolute figures of a change in BP
Dollar by exchange rate here you can see
how the volatility fluctuations here
and the same goes with the risk-free
interest rate you can also see the
absolute figures of you know the lag
here of the risk-free interest rate and
finally you can see the absolute
deviation of inflation rate from its
mean so so all these results are like
you know time varying volatility so you
can see how it has the volatility has
been changing between the different time
period so that's what this example is
all talks about here
now let's talk about Arts model process
so before I actually deep dive in and
talk about you know Arch model uh
process uh let's try to you know analyze
or you know understand in which
situations or know which cases we
actually use the RX models uh for
instance let's say you know we are
fitting the ARP model uh and uh we can
see that you know the residual looks
like a full of a white noise but we are
concerned about the decay of P lag Wells
on the ACF plots of the series so I'll
talk in detail about the ACF and psef
plots in in the next coming slides for
now just know follow me with the flow to
understand the context
uh so so during this process what we can
do is if we are able to figure out that
you know we can apply the square of a
residual as well so in that case we can
know we can confirm and say that you
know we have a positive indication
saying that you know Arch is an
appropriate in this particular case uh
to put it in a simple way uh so we can
say that Arch model is indeed or not no
when you know by uh squaring the
residuals and examining the ACF plots
and we during this process we also need
to make sure that our mean of variance
would be we know B into mean of should
be a zero and also there should not be
any a trend and seasonality patterns in
order to apply acts model for our time
series data this is something you know
we should uh remember while we are
building the arch model process
okay now let's try to understand this
Arch model process so we'll begin with
uh at one process here so there are so
many mathematical formulas and equations
involved in terms of you know explaining
the arch model process but you know what
I decided is like you know I really
don't want to uh show all the formulas
and equations behind this process
because to be honest I really do not
want to scare you with so much of
mathematics here so instead what I've
done is like you know I picked up I
picked up an example uh and to walk you
through the process and also the
underlying math behind this each process
so that you know you can grab the
context easily you know that was my
motive behind putting this example here
okay so the art one process is we so
here this is an example of a simulation
of a hundred observations of a H1
processor and ar1 by Arch one processes
here now if you look at the first visual
here which shows the white noise so
white noise is making is nothing but you
know all variables are independent
identifying with the mean of a zero here
so these are all independent variable
with a mean of a zero which you can see
in the white noise and next we have the
conditional standard deviation here so
the conditional standard division
indicates if the EET uh so what we do so
to mathematically explain this process
what we are doing is Sigma T here so
where we are doing a root of one plus uh
0.95 Sigma Alpha of T minus one so so
these are the parameters which have been
used in this example so what with this
formula is basically doing is it's
generating the conditional standard
deviation process in this example so
when we apply this technique so it
generates a conditional standard
deviation process
okay once the conditional standard
deviation process is done so now we can
see the arch process here so which we
can see which are seeing in the visual
three so how we can achieve this Arts
process is mathematically when we apply
the alpha T equals to no Sigma t plus e
t so the e t is not so e t is nothing
but the error term here and the
previously T minus one are nothing but
you know we are considering the previous
values uh for no for our Arch models
here so now the arch one process can be
used as a noise of a AR model here so
which you can see here so which you are
seeing in this particular case here so
once we have done this Arch process
now what we are doing is so here the
parameters here are the MU is equal to
0.1 and the Phi is equal to 0.8 in this
parameters so once we have done now now
we are calculating the variance of our
onward
is like you know uh with a Y of alpha 0
equals to no this is the formula where
now we are taking 1 of 1 minus 0.95
figures which is the parameters here
which results to a standard deviation of
a 20. so our standard deviation is equal
to root of 20 which symbolize a 4.47 now
if you see the visuals from you know e
to H here
into H here the process of Art and also
the art squared so if You observe the
Arts process does not have any
correlation here but if you see the R
square it has the correlations this is
something you know which really we need
to understand uh and it's an important
you know when we are building that
environment so during that process we do
not say any correlation but when we
apply R square so we'll see the
correlations coming into the picture so
that is uh a laboratory Arch processor
so maybe at this point if you are not
able to I I somehow as that it's quite
you know difficult to understand the
underlying method or by listening into
theoretical but don't worry we have uh
some you know practical way how we can
deal with you know in a practical
approach I'm sure you'll you will get a
clear idea about what's all happening in
this visuals and underlying math uh
behind this process
and now similarly uh the same thing goes
with the arch 2 process like you know
what we are doing here since here in the
in the previous one we have taken the
previous day values here we are taking
the previous two days values and we are
constructing the arch model uh and the
same thing up to the P process like you
know up to the number of observations
which we want to take and our final
formula looks like this uh uh this is
our defining formula looks like that and
the parameter used during this R like
you know the P the p and I are very
important parameters in this like you
know p is nothing but the number of uh
lag squared residual errors to be
included in our Arch model and I is
nothing but the lager period number of
lagged period Square errors and one
important thing which you would like
always has to remember while we are
building uh working on Arch model
processes like in our volatility should
not be negative because our voltage
should always be positive so it doesn't
make sense like you know uh if the
volatile is actually negative in match
model process so that is something
important you should hear keep in your
mind next we'll see the catch model
process so the catch model process uh is
so this example is an extension of the
previous Arch model process as I
mentioned that you know is a gut is an
extension for Arch model process that
indicates uh a moving average component
uh in incorporates a moving average
component with an auto regulatory
component so you have both moving
average and auto regressive components
involved in the gatch component so the
catch one one here are nothing but you
know we have a one uh autorig Refuge lag
and one moving average Lab so the one by
one is nothing but lag lag values here
of Auto regular review and the moving
average
and you know comparatively with Arch
guards purchased a like a wide range of
a behavior in particularly with more
persistent volatility so you'll see the
volatility much like but it's much
better comparatively with the arch model
so that's a beauty of Arts model so I'll
not walk you through the all steps which
I have talked in the art slides again
the process all the remain same but I
would like to stretch an important Point
here so now if you see the result from
you know e to H here the conditional
standard deviation is not much bursted
comparatively with the Arts process so
you see here it's the the bursting of uh
see the variance bursting is very you
know less comparatively with what we
have seen in the uh Arch one process so
visual so that's that's the uh that's
the key here of our gatch one modeling
processors and you know so these are the
parameters which we have been used to
solve this sample of the catchment
process and similarly for the you know
got PQ so this is a Formula here uh
theoretical formula so where what we are
doing is like you know Alpha I and you
know the DJ are basically the parameters
of our model here and what we are doing
is when we are acting when we are the
moving average so it is basically taking
the values based on T minus G so when we
are applying the moving average here so
it is basically taking the values from
this uh T minus J uh values uh so that's
how the when we are trying to build a
batch PQ process model works so uh
uh I somehow you know guess that you
know uh most of you folks have
definitely have some you know blank
faces or a confused phase at this point
of time for different for sure uh but
don't worry try to follow me with the
flow uh at this point but but I'll make
sure that you know by the end of the
presentation you really have you know
fade idea about you know what will we
discuss and because you'll be seeing
everything in a practical approach so
I'm sure you'll connect all the dots for
sure uh so you know for now just trust
me and uh follow me with the flow
okay next uh we'll talk about how we can
build a arch and guards models so as
I've been talking earlier that you know
uh more a lot about you know
autocorrelation and the partial
correlation plot so now it's time to
talk in detail about all these plots so
all these Auto correlation and partial
correlation plots are heavily used in a
Time series analysis in forecasting
because these plots summarize the
strength of a relationship with an
observation in any time series or with
observation in any prior 10 steps so
that's the beauty about the auto
correlation plots now uh with the help
of like you know autocorrelation and
plots of variants so we can we can
configure the guts and Arch models and
it can be better understood by looking
at the visually so when we plot the ACF
no and partial correlation plots you can
understand the uh guards model and Arch
processes much better how the variance
is showcasing by looking at the visual
so that's the uh that's the key role
that no Auto correlation partial
correlation plots play in the time
series uh
and once we have configured the model
right so now we'll be subtracting the
mean from each observation this queries
and squaring the outcome so once this
has been done now we can interpret to
estimate the values of our p and Q
parameters that we you know we do for
you know our Arma model so so you'll be
seeing all that you know in a while now
foreign
and finally once we build the model then
our goal final goal is to forecast the
model so so this is how the process
works for forecasting model so for what
we like you will initially load the data
then we'll plot the visualization we'll
plot the ECF and an obesity of plots the
correlation to see whether there is
evidence of a volatility clustering in
our
in our data plot under the plots which
we have built and once the visualization
has been done we'll test for Arts
effects and so once the test after the
test effects has been done then we'll
see whether we can reject the null
hypothesis of a arch effects because if
we are not able to reject the null
hypothesis of heart attack then there is
no point of no uh predicting the arch
models because it doesn't make any sense
when we are able to reject the null
hypothesis of arch model then which it
will have a positive indication now we
are able to predict a predict the
estimate of a Arts model which we do in
the step four once we have been done
we'll interpret the results so that's
how the structure of a forecasting model
works like and the same thing goes with
the gacha as well so we load the data
we'll plot the visualization and we'll
test for Arch effects so if the test if
the arch effects are available then will
present will estimate already the guards
model and once the model has been
predicted and will interpret the results
so this is how the overall uh process
works uh of here uh to Showcase you on a
theoretically so what next we have is
like you know we'll see uh everything in
action now so how we can build guards
and model of models with the python and
you know other machine learning stuff so
let me uh quickly
yeah I just wanted to uh remind you I
think we have about nine minutes
remaining of your talk uh if you want to
allocate some time for uh q a through
the audience
so just yeah I mean like so just give me
uh the main time I'll just quickly walk
through the code and explain the process
absolutely thanks
yeah sure
oh
sure
so so what I've done if he uh so instead
of something considering the time
constraint I'll not talk about uh I mean
like a sample model here so instead uh
I'll talk about the the model which I
built so in this section what I've done
is like you know we are taking the
real-time stock data and building the
cars model to to see the volatility of
the stock here so I will put a necessary
suspect here so we are predicting so I
have taken the Tesla stock because uh
because Ln musk is everywhere trending
these days so yes foreign
stock here so I'm giving the data like
you know 2015 to 2020 uh with the help
of panda data reader I am reading the
data and you know I'm plotting the
visuals now you can see that you know we
can feed good volatility here you know
from 2015 to 2020 you can see the
fluctuations how it has been changing
from 2015 to 50 shift 20. now this is a
good sign for now building a guards
model uh because uh it has a quite High
volatility here now with the help of a
now pacf plot like as I mentioned as
I've discussed in the slides like
partial correlation plots I'm trying to
plot here the partial Coalition now you
can see that you know uh up to three
lakhs it has a very good increasing
Trend and slightly it was decreasing in
the different periods now considering
the three as our lag parameters uh for p
and Q so I'm building the building the
guards these remodel which is nothing
but I don't know three Auto regressive
uh lags and a three moving average uh
lakhs here so p is equal to three Q is
equal to three where I'm building a
model I'm fitting the model here now
this is how we'll see we'll observe the
results in the summary part so so if you
look at the alpha and beta summary
results here uh it pretty much shows
that you know uh but Alpha is good so
far better beta is not that great
because uh if you see some of the
parameters in beta are not that
significant here so what we can do is we
can we are able to drop this values uh
so again for what I'm doing I've dropped
the values now I'm taking the guts again
I'm again taking the process I've got
3.0 which is nothing but R3 here so here
I'm passing the p is equal to 3 in Q is
equal to 0 because I've dropped the
previous Q values here now again I'm
plotting build the model and summary now
you can see that our parameters looks
much consistent here now now we are good
to consider this model okay now that we
have a good uh prediction estimate now
how can we decide uh whether our model
is able to predict the volatility of a
Tesla stock very well or not so with the
help of rolling forecast origin so we
are predicting so here I am taking the
test size as a 365 days what it will do
is like you know it will uh it will
calculate the guts modeling process for
each of the day in 365 days and predict
for the next day out so that's how the
process will work here so I'm taking all
the 365 days here and the rolling
prediction when I visualize now you can
see here so the orange line is nothing
but the true returns which you have seen
in the above plot like you know the same
plot actual returns and the predictor
one is you are seeing in the purple line
now your so the so here our object is
not to ask not to compare like how both
are like you know how both are like
familiar no I mean to say how uh how how
our inline exactly matches line with the
purple line my goal is to say how it it
how the predicted line is catching up
the volatility when the actual return is
also jumpy like Financial team solve the
jumpy our predictable is also able to
catch up so this is where our cat that's
model is able to catching up all these
things so that's the beauty of the uh
guards model here and so I've done the
same example for other I mean like other
equity for SNP but of but the final
thing I would like to show yes once we
have I mean like once you have taken uh
build the like visualize the predictor
volatility now it's time that you know
we have to focus our model so what I've
done here is for s p Equity so we have
built till the visualization I mean you
have seen all this part in the previous
one now I'm forecasting I'm going to
predict the next seven days how my model
will able to predict how my guards model
will able to predict so for that I am
taking the seven days now you can see
that you know so it has been increasing
it has been slightly decreasing in this
particular date again it's increasing
it's been decreasing and overall this is
how so now this is the this is how it we
can focus the model like you know this
forecast is for a short term but when we
go for long term right I mean it becomes
less certain so it's always good to look
for the shortened time margin so so but
these uh so to conclude that you know
these plots like you know these plots
really play important role for people
who are like you know watching the
moments of the stock market are the
investors they can make a decision
whether to buy or sell the stock based
on if it's a if it's going to be very
volatile or completely not so this place
these plots plays a very key role in
terms of understanding and finally I
would like to say that you know the data
and the plots which I've shown in here
are discussed about the all the
financial data or the financial thing
which I talked is purely uh to guide you
the concept of arts and gods I mean like
which is not nowhere I'm you know
addressing for an investment purpose so
so so this is something you should keep
in mind and with that uh with that uh
I'll uh uh these are the references for
the talk uh with that I know I'll
conclude my talk and if you have again
if you have anything for me feel free to
write in this platforms and I'll be
happy to uh address the questions uh for
sure and uh yeah with that uh I can
conclude my talk now excellent thanks oh
yeah thanks very much I've always been
quite interested in arts and Coach
models uh so this is a nice quick
overview of it uh there are I think two
questions in in from the audience
um I can uh show them on the screen the
first one is by kiril Duncan uh he's
asking this person is asking what are
some recommended packages for python to
use Arch or garch here there is a pack
uh so there is a package of arch
packages available on a python so you
can now explore the arch package of
python uh so maybe uh uh let me just let
me go to my code uh I'll just share you
here
so
yeah sure so this is how I'm just giving
the import idea here but uh so where can
I paste I can paste it in the chat or
the comments
I think I don't have right
okay so so so yeah so I can tell you
that you know there is a package of arch
maybe if you can Google write in a
python Arch so you'll find it uh the
package name so yeah you can start uh
using back and you can start exporting
playing with the arch and guards models
yes oh yeah sorry uh uh Circle so uh
yeah you can also uh paste the link in
Discord uh if if the audience uh joins
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
correct you can ping me in the Discord I
mean like I'll be there in the Discord
I'll I'll do that excellent and one last
question uh before you wrap up there was
a question by Glenn Lehman is the code
available for us to review
yeah sure I mean like I'll share the
code notebook so I I didn't publish it I
mean like I built it in yesterday night
I was just sitting I don't know writing
all this code from scratch so I didn't
get a time to publish it but I'll
definitely you know do it uh make it
public for sure because it's everything
is open source right so there is nothing
uh yeah complicated here yeah excellent
it's very nice to know all right uh
thank you very much Kelly and once more
for your quick tour of the Arts and
gutsch models uh very it's a very nice
talk and I'm sure the audience is very
appreciative of it
all right
yeah thank you thank you thank you so
much for having me in uh my data again
uh it's an honor to speak here and yeah
I'll see you all later and have a great
conference